Yeah.
One of the things that,
the question of what's uniquely humans
is actually a big one.
Um,
and you,
depending on who you ask,
you might get really different answers.
If I had to put my money on something
that was actually uniquely human,
it seems in some funny way to be our
motivation to actually interact with
others in a funny way.
And what I mean by this is that,
uh,
you know,
generally if you look at any humans
anywhere,
if they're hanging out with other
humans,
they're often doing something where
they're showing something to another
individual.
So you see something cool,
you say,
Oh hey,
look at this cool thing and to
psychologist this is this process of
reference,
right?
Sort of share referring to information
out there in a world.
And it seems like other primates,
even though you think this is kind of a
simple ability,
they seem to lack at least the
motivation to do this.
Um,
this leads to the fact that they don't
have the kind of communication that we
have your things like language with now.
And so it can kind of point to things
out there.
In the world.
Um,
they also don't seem to share their own
desires and intentions with others,
which leads to a lack of kind of
cooperation and a lot of domains.
So,
so if I had to put my money on what was
uniquely human,
I'd,
I'd go with a kind of motivation to
share information with others.